weeks before the january 6 riot at the
u.s capitol far-right protesters some
who would later turn violent in
washington illegally occupied the state
capitol building in arizona
joe biden won the swing state but donald
trump and his supporters refused to
accept defeat trump's attorney rudy
giuliani called arizona's republican
house speaker demanding help to overturn
the results he would say
aren't we all republicans here i said
look
you are asking me to do something
that is counter to my oath trump also
lost in the swing state of georgia he
himself called the state's top election
official republican brad raffensberger i
just want to find
11
780
[Music]
votes which is one more that we have
what i knew is that we didn't have any
votes to find raffensburger testified
that he and his family suffered
harassment from trump supporters
including sexually explicit messages to
his wife and someone breaking into his
daughter-in-law's home i think sometimes
moments require you to stand up
and just take the shots
we just followed the lawn we followed
the constitution
and at the end of the day president
trump came up short
trump also turned up the pressure on two
everyday americans mother and daughter
election workers in georgia falsely
accusing them of counting fake ballots
we had
at least 18 000 that's on tape we had
them counted
very
painstakingly 18 000 voters uh having to
do with ruby freeman that's she's a vote
scammer a professional vote scammer and
hustler do you know how it feels to have
the president of the united states to
target you
the president of the united states is
supposed to represent every american
not to target one
but he targeted me an investigation has
cleared both women of wrongdoing and
widespread voting fraud was never found
in any state our democracy held because
courageous people like those you heard
from today put their oath
to the constitution
above their loyalty to one man or to one
party
the system held but barely and the
question remains will it hold again
even before tuesday's hearing began
trump posted on his website that his
phone call pressuring georgia's
secretary of state to find votes was
quote perfect he called the january 6th
committee crazed democrats and again
falsely alleged that the election was
stolen
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington